this I will be talking about a joint
work with the original from the vitamin
Institute so let me parse the title for
you the parallel repetition is something
that comes up in the context of
interactive proofs and but it has you
know applications beyond this in
particular for hotness of approximation
and what we do here is we saw some
connection between repetition and
certain things from analysis
particularly sources related to certain
operator norms and this will allow us to
give new proves that are simpler and
proof better bounds so let me first also
talk to explain parallel petition in
this original language of interactive
proofs so our basic objects are two
player one round games and they are
specified by constraint by the following
kind of constraint graph so it's a
bipartite graph between two vertex sets
in U and V and the edges are decorated
by constraints these constraints will in
it so for this works we will talk and
we'll focus on certain kinds of
constraints called projection
constraints and that will be maps from
some alphabet Sigma to itself now given
such a constraint graph it specifies the
game G in the following way so there are
two parties a listen to play us Alice
and Bob and in the referee now the game
goes as follows so the referee samples
around a match from the graph and it
gives the right vertex to you to ellis
and the left vertex to bob and then the
the players respond with some symbol
from the alphabet say alpha and better
and the players win if if the if their
responses satisfy the constraint that we
have on the edge the referee picked ok
and in the context of so if you have
projection constraints or if you have
these kind of constraints then what it
means to satisfy the constraint is that
the alphabet symbol alpha that Ellis
replied with is mapped by pi to the
alphabet symbol that Bob reply to it
okay so action constraint now what's
important is that during the course of
this game the play to play us a lesson
Bob they are not allowed to communicate
so they only interact with with the
referee and so that means that the
responses that the responses of the
players only depend on the vertices that
they receive from the referee okay
particular it so you can check that or
it turns out that there are optimal
strategies for Edison Bob that just
corresponds to assignments of alphabet
symbols to the vertices a few and
assignments of output symbols to the
vertices of V then the you know Ellis
replies with F of you and Bob replies
with govt of the value of the game is
defined to be the maximum success
probability of all strategies for the
players so it means it oh you go over
all assignments fmg further further the
graph and you maximize this this happens
probability given such a game we we yes
you can associate a computational
problem with it is this problem is
called labor cover so given a game and
you're supposed to estimate the value of
the game and this problem turns out to
be very important very useful in
particular it's the starting point of
most partners approximation reductions
now given such a game there's a natural
operation that you can apply to it this
operation is called parallel petition so
the K forward parallel repeated game
goes as follows so the referee pics not
just one edge from the graph but k
address uniformly at random he sends the
right vertices to Ellis and the left
vertices to Bob now the players respond
with the alphabet symbols and they win
if if all of their replies satisfy the
constraints that the referee picked ok
oh the question will be
how does the value of this repeated game
behave as a function of the value of the
one shot of the of the original game and
the number of repetitions that's to
verify the situation here so if we would
look at strategies for the players where
the ice ultimate symbol that is Ellis
responsible depends only on the ice
vertex that she receives okay which
means that the coordinates are
independent then the success probability
before such of such strategies is it
most the value of the game race to the K
but but here you know in this context
the alphabet symbol that Ellis responds
with it could depend on all the vertices
that she got from the referee pieces
there could be correlations between the
coordinates and so this is a question so
the goal is to understand how much these
this correlation can help the players to
win the game oh okay so what do we know
about this question but there's a long
history and there will only give you a
very short version of it and there's
also this discretion is also notorious
in particular the proofs are famously
difficult and the first proofs about it
not correct and the main result in this
context is parallel petition theorem due
to run r us and it says that if the
value of the of the original game is
founded away from one then the value of
the repeated game decays exponentially
the number of repetitions in the rate
the rate of the decay you know it
depends on value of the original game
but it's important i said if this is a
no bond away from one then this is also
bounded away from one this result has
been improved subsys over the years and
so that's the current best bound
turns out that this quadratic dependence
on on epsilon is tight even for very
simple kind of constraints called extra
constraints it's one reason why this
result is interesting and useful is
because you can use it in 422 to show
hardnesses a chocolate artists
approximation results in particular you
can use pal reputation as a reduction to
amplify hardness of this label cover
problem in this way you're starting from
the basic PCP theorem you can show that
it's NP hard to distinguish between
games that have value 1 and games that
have value Delta for every positive
constant Delta this this this this
hardness is the starting point of many
NP hardness select any hardness of
approximation reductions but it turns
out that they are very simple questions
about parallel petition that are not
addressed by by this result because let
me for example we can ask what happens
if the value of the starting game is a
little off one okay it's already very
small now if sort of look at this case
it corresponds to and you know epsilon
being close to 1 and so that means that
this here you know because there is some
constant let me loose epsilon you know
this year would be something like half
okay so they said would you know then
this this this bound would tell you that
the value of the repeated game is at
most 2 to the minus K or something like
that but that's you know if you think
about it that's not very useful in terms
of amplification because you know you
already know that the original game had
sub constant value okay so so 2 2 minus
K unless you know in this context k is a
constant input minus K is larger than
the value of the regional game so it's
so this is this point is not useful in
this case another case where this point
does not apply is when when K is small
compared to 1 over epsilon ok so then
again it turns out that the bounty that
you get because you have epsilon squared
it's actually
Archer than the value of the original
game okay so it means that for both of
these cases the this dispone test does
not say something interesting indeed in
this work we will we will resolve both
of these questions we saw show
palpitation theorems for into in these
two cases and the lib o our proofs are
based on unknown and to show these
results we developed some analytical
framework to analyze Bell repetition and
this is in contrast to two previous
results that they were based on an
information theoretic approach but
concretely be sure the following 22
bounds which oh that if the value of the
sonic game is the most role then the the
the value of the repeated game decays
exponentially at a rate that is roughly
square root of R oh ok but so this is
you know useful if if Rho is this is
respondus is meaningful also even if Rho
is sub constant if she's the kind of
decay that you expect and we also show
that in context if number of repetitions
is small let me show that the was the
value of the game is 1 minus epsilon it
turns out that the value of the repeated
game decays exactly at the rate of 1
minus epsilon however it's not
exponential in the number of repetitions
but in the number in the square root of
the number of repetitions ok so the kind
of decatur you get out after repeating
the game k times it's like you you
repeat it again square root K times why
are these bounce yes yeah
I mean I think maybe none of those
statements imply the top seven births
but this framework also allows you to
prove this statement
not sure if the I don't know if I know
if a good a good question that is I mean
I don't know if a regime of epsilon K
there where there's some open question
yeah but I'm also not sure if this
really why are these so what can you use
the useless bounds for so one one
implication of these bounces it's an
optimal np-hardness reduction for set
cover okay so get set cover some basic
optimization problem and so that's a
simple krieger algorithm that achieves a
log and approximation factor it's really
sort of the natural logarithm of n as
the approximation ratio and it turns out
that this is this is tied so so the way
up addresses that's my guy did it show
did you know there was a whatsapp oh no
Meah time reduction for this for this
approximation ratio so but this doesn't
show that the problem is np-hard in the
usual sense and using using this bound
bound in the replies in the low belly
regime and results by Mozgov it's
Sandra's you you you will get an NP
hardness reduction for this
approximation ratio and moreover you can
settle exactly the time approximation
trade-off for this problem so turns out
that there's an algorithm that runs in
time to to the end to the epsilon it
achieves this approximation ratio you
know a little bit better than log in and
this the hunter seduction that we get
from this from this bound exactly
matches this this algorithm such joy
said you know really the time complexity
of achieving this kind of approximation
ratio for set cover is 2 to the N to the
theta of epsilon under some standard
complexity assumptions the
the bound to the applies for small
values of K it shows that the counter
example for pale repetition due to run
Russ is tight slipping in the in the
full full range of of K okay so run
razgovor show that there are games that
have value 1 minus epsilon and the value
of the k fo repeated game is 1 minus
epsilon x is at least one myself
sometimes root k and so this this
matches this bound so this answers a no
question due to Ryan or Don let me know
in overview of the proof so this is
really like a more like a cartoon or a
very rough overview so the wood we
define so the proof caused by defining a
parameter which we call the relaxed
value of a game okay and then we show
three properties about this relax this
parameter and these three properties
will allow you to prove by reputation
bones okay so first of all the relaxed
value is always at least the least as
large as the value of the game and
second property is that the wrecks value
is multiplicative so if you you know
repeat the game k times then the relaxed
value the repeated game is the reacts
value of G or race to the king the third
property is that the rest value is a
good approximation for the value of the
game so it's the red X values have a
much larger than the true value of it
now how do these three properties and so
so one thing that I should point out
here maybe said this flex disc this
parameter mmm it will not be developed
it's NP hard to compute okay so which is
not surprising in this context but its
necessary because otherwise it cannot
have this approximation property so now
how do these three properties imply and
bounce on the value of parity pearl
repetition so first you know we want
about it is we want to bound the value
of the repeated game so because I don't
first we can upper bounded by the
relaxed value of the repeated game now
because reacts value is multiplicative
we can we can relate it to the red
reacts value of the original game and
now because relaxed value is a good
approximation for the value of the game
we can in turn related to the value of
the original game allows you to show
bounds in the parallel petition on the
value of the parallel petition of a game
this approach is not it's not you in
particular Fagin lowbies suggested this
approach and they they shorted some some
parameter that satisfies the first two
properties but it turns out it doesn't
satisfy the third property and in some
sense the the reason why it couldn't
satisfy the third property because this
parameter was a semi different program
and you know these nice things are easy
to compute but you know no easy to
compute relaxation can satisfy the third
property because you know you're talking
about me because estimating the value of
these kind of games is an np-hard
problem and in something that's exactly
what by we you know may be interested in
this and so the parameter that we we
will use is some sensible is related to
the parameter suggested by Fagin louvers
it's but it's not a semi-literate
program so cementation programs you can
think of it as some optimization problem
over over the cone of positive
semi-definite matrices and our parameter
you can do it view it as the analog but
instead of optimizing over positive 17
matrices you optimize other matrices
that have no negative Jaleski
factorizations so matrices that you can
write as x x transpose the excess
non-negative matrix so ng x is
non-negative and these things are not
easy to compute and there's also an if
you lots of you this our parameter is
similar to related to to a parameter
called the helling a value which was
introduced in a paper by Barack hard how
we've row and reg f in myself
comes from the notion of Helena distance
between probability distributions this
is the overview so now to explain some
more details about the profile I want to
introduce this this analytical setup
that allows you to us to talk about
pearl repetition in analytical language
and so so this is the basis we want to
talk talk about ok so the basis will be
to understand the this constraint graph
in a slightly different way so so here
first of all maybe we will talk about
operators in this context and a nice way
to specify operators in terms of crafts
ok so so let's talk about cross so this
is a constraint graph and what you don't
like about this constraint graph is that
the edges are decorated by these
constraints and so we want to
incorporate this into the into the craft
structure and so let me show you how to
do this so first of all we replace every
vertex of this constraint graph by the
cloud of vertices one vertex for every
alphabet symbol okay and then we replace
every constraint by a bunch of edges
between these two clouds and exactly
sort of we replace you know we put edges
according to the between alphabets
symbols that are that are consistent you
know according to this this constraint
the absolute simple alpha and gets you
know gets connected to better if it is
this map naps alpha to beta now and this
is this graph is called the label it's
in a graph now we will we will look at
you can look at function real value
functions on the vertices of this graph
so we have some function f on the one
function G some real value functions on
these vertices we can we can view this
this craft
SN this graph you know specifies the
game and we can view this craft know as
a linear operator that maps a function
related function on these vertices to a
function on these vertices so how does
how this is operator act so or so
another way to think about this operator
said is you know it corresponds to the
adjacency matrix of this graph so let me
tell you how this operator X on these
functions so so to compute the value of
G of the operator G applied to to the
function f at the vertex V comma better
you can compute in the following way so
you average over the neighbors of
average over the neighbors of B and then
you sum over the over the aphid symbols
that are consistent with better ok and
you look at the you know the values that
F has set these points you know real
corresponds to the adjacency matrix of
this graph or now there are certain kind
of functions that are now it turns out
that there's some kind of special
functions on these vertices which will
be useful us and because these will call
these functions assignments so an
assignment is a function that it maps
that takes non-negative values and if
you look at one cloud here the values if
you sum of the values in one cloud you
get one it's equal to one ok so you know
for example in you know and one way one
way to get an assignment is that you
know you assign one to exactly one
vertex in each clout ok so that's that's
an assignment but you're also allowed to
you know assign fractional values as
long as they sum up to one for every
cloud now if you have if F is such an
assignment then there's a you know
probabilistic interpretation of what
this operator is doing so you can so the
value of G applied to F at the point V
comma better is is equal to the
probability that a random neighbor of of
V demands the alphabet symbol better
in order to you know to be consistent
this interpretation it allows us to know
to to specify the value of a game in in
more analytical way so you can look at
the the bilinear form corresponding to
to the matrix G okay find like this now
if if if both F and G are assignments
then the value of this pile uniform is
exactly equal to the to this through the
success probability of the of the
players okay this allows us not to know
that we can talk about the value of a
game in terms of in terms of this
analytical set up so we would value of
the game is equal to the maximum of this
bilinear form over all assignments f and
g now if you know how to talk about the
value of a game in this language now we
want to talk about power repetition in
this language and turns out that there's
a very simple way to talk about parallel
petition in this framework suppose we
want to play G in one coordinate and
then we want to play h in parallel in
another coordinate ok so we have these
two games you want to play them in
parallel then it turns out that it
corresponds exactly the operator
corresponding to this new game
corresponds exactly to the tensor
product of the of the operators for g +
44 h so they many ways of thinking the
different ways of thinking about detains
a product of operators but this
definition here sort of it be hmm it
makes it clear it really corresponds to
a parallel petition ok so you know the
want to look at what what g tensor H
applied to f at the point at you know at
some point V V Prime better better prime
is and we would pick two random edges
you know want one random edge from g and
one random edge from h and then we would
we would sum over the advert symbols
that are consistent with better and
other servers that are consistent with
better prime and the values the
actions f takes them in okay so it turns
out that one bbbff ova i can show you
the proof so that there says everyone
simplifying step which which makes
things sink smell things much easier so
we will will find you want to find a
good proxy for the value of the game
which is slightly nicer okay and this
proxy will be you know so will be to
maximize the norm of G applied to F over
all assignments f and we look at the
tune on here the claim is that this
value is you know is it approximates the
value of the game very closely so let's
see why that's true first you know the
value of the game SSR before it is equal
to you know the bilinear form of G
applied you know at some assignments F
and G now by koshish roads you can avoid
it by the middle norm of three times F
in the norm of G and turns out that if
you have an assignment G then the norm
of f it is obvious is most one is it's
almost one so it means that you know the
value of the game is at most the this
norm of V times F so the other direction
is it would be would sum over the
attribute symbols so it's a too long so
so the yeah the measure that we use is
that you you know you average over the
vertices and you sum over the alphabet
symbols yes let me show you why the
other direction I mean why the this norm
is never much larger than the value of
the game so you know the week means it's
a tool of G times F and we can now open
up the to Nome and think of it as the
inner product of GF with itself now it
turns out that if if G corresponds to
you know is because G is this projection
game it turns out that if you look at
this function G apply to F and F is an
assignment then also G times f is an
assignment ok but it means that would be
I feel
you know the the bar uniform of G
evaluated at some assignment F and some
other assignments as in some other
assignment to G times if ok and so this
means that you know this is this is it
mostly square root of the value of the
game because yeah you know the bilinear
form of G evaluated at two assignments
now so let me so this a let me show you
some of that the simplest theorem that
you can prove using this framework that
is interesting for hundreds of others in
proc summation in the interval is what
is a part of approximation so here's the
statement suppose that the constraint
graph is an expander in the sense that s
the constant eigenvalue cap and this is
you know for the purpose of hardness
hardness amplification this is very easy
to ensure now we want to show the
following we want to show that if the
value of the repeated game is larger
than 1 minus a to the K go to show that
this implies that there's the value of
the original game is it's at least 1
minus order a charm he so for some
constant that depends on maybe the
eigenvalue camp of that depends on the
eigenvalue gave of the constraint proof
this is like the contrapositive of this
power repetition bound ok so i want to
show you know i want to show that if the
value of the repeated game is large then
the value of the original game is it's
also about ok I mean so so so if for
some k the value starter than this then
the value ok so the proof
theorem is in two steps both are very
simple so so the first step is I want to
show that suppose that the value of
supposed to the norm of G tens ok so
first you know because I mean I said I
explained it you know instead of talking
about the value we can talk about these
these norms because they are good proxy
for the value of a game so I said if the
norm of the P tense is decayed apply to
F its larger than 1 minus e to the K for
some assignment f it implies that they
exist some non negative negative
function f such that the norm of G times
F is at least 1 minus ETA times the norm
of T times F so what is T so T will be
the operator corresponding to some
trivial game ok so let's not let's not
worry about it it is this point so it's
all said ok so he nice thing is about
what happens here is that you know be we
have something about g tensor you know
the repeated game and and beget a
consequence about the original game ok
no so given such a function or negative
function where this ratio between these
norms is it's large and it turns out
that you can extract an assignment for
the for the game it has value close to
one ok and maybe just to explain things
so this is in the second step we will
use the fact the constraint graph is an
expander this first step is sort of true
generic
the first step so suppressed in wife to
should have to explain what we are
shooting for here so we have to explain
what t is so tease the game course you
know this latex in a graph okay so you
see that you know we have the same you
if we have you have these clouds and on
you know the other side we have the same
kind of clothes and all the alphabet
symbols are mapped to the same alphabet
symbol on the left okay so what this
means is that you know if you know no
matter what assignment we have on the
right now as long as Bob always you know
always replies with this alphabet symbol
you know the first half a bit simple the
players win the game with probability 1
okay so that's the game comes pinning to
you but you know you can just think of
it as an operator so notes the operating
operator course with this in a
corresponding to the adjacency matrix of
this craft oh okay so this is operated
SSSs nice properties so first of all we
know for any assignment for on the right
the norm of T applied to F is equal to 1
no matter what what assignment you use
here because you know the various
operator X is that it will sum up the
values that we have here and because
it's an assignment this dissemble e will
be equal to 1 okay none so it means that
this is function G times f it will have
it will be one for all these afterward
symbols and zero reveals and that will
be a function it has no unborn nothing
nother property of this operator is that
or this game t is that it behaves well
with parallel petition so in some set it
doesn't you know it doesn't change the
value if you have some some arbitrary
game h and we play this game t and
parallel with it it doesn't change the
value of of the of the game the reason
is that it's you know we actually only
only use one of the directions you know
that that this value is at most this
value but this is obvious because you
know if you have some sort of if you
play some some game in parallel with
another game the
the value you know cannot increase this
is what we are shooting for here and now
so we have to understand what this
assumption means and so I want you to
use the assumption in the following so
okay so I want to say that without loss
of generality we can assume that if we
sort of repeat g only k minus 1 times
and then look at G repeated with the tea
then this function f achieves you know
that achieves the value of at most 1
minus H are raised to the K minus 1 so
the reason why why we can assume this is
so there are different ways of thinking
about you can either think about it as
some kind of hybrid hybrid argument by
your sort of replace you know
coordinates you know Gordon's of g with
copies of you know by-by things up with
T another way to think about it says
some kind of induction so you know
suppose you know suppose is not true you
know suppose that this you know the norm
of of this guy is larger than 1 minus a
to the K minus 1 okay so then I I claim
that i can reduce k by one okay the
reason is that you know if you know if
this here i mean if if this norm is
large then also it you know if i remove
t here i can find a function where this
is large okay and so it means that you
know the exists of some some assignment
f such that the norm of g-rated k minus
1 x is at least 1 minus HR to the K
minus 1 ok so the means that we are in
the same situation is here but k is one
smaller and so this is good for you so
you know it's like some kind of trivial
argument it's so it suggests you know
make this assumption that if we replace
you know one copy of G here with T then
the value is smaller than 1 1 minus 80
to the Caymans not in this situation no
let's simplify things a bit so let's
call this game you know G repeated k
minus 1 times let's call it h you know
it's some some some
some game and now the situation we are
in is the following we know we have some
function f and if we if we if we play G
and H in parallel for the with the
assignment f then the value that we get
is 1 minus H R times larger than the
value at we get if we just play t okay
this is just because you know we assume
that you know playing G K times gives us
this kind of value and we assume that
playing this game gives us at most 1
minus H R times this is really the just
simplifying the city of situation now
now let it let me draw a picture of
already have so we have this function f
and it's any yourself is to you can
think of it as some kind of two
dimensional function so but 11 part of f
is indexed by things corresponding to 2g
and and in the other part are things
corresponding to h ok you have this
function f and you can think of it as a
two dimensional function and we apply
this operator g tensor edge to it and we
get another function and we have this
other operator you know t tensor h and
apply to FV you get me get this kind of
function ok we get to two if you get
these two dimensional functions if we
apply these these operators to f now the
you know the promise of the f is that
that if you look at the norm of this
function it's at least the norm of this
function x 1 minus ETA now so you know
suppose you know even if you didn't
follow these things what what they have
here is really the you know the basic
question about parallel petition ok so
we have you know if you have some
assignment for we have some assignment f
and we are playing the game g tensor
edge on this assignment ok
and and then we are playing you know
this game on this on this assignment in
this game is really just the same as t
sh sh ok so here you know if you go the
top route then we play G repeated with H
and if you go with a button route we
just play the game h ok and we are told
that you know that if you play the game
G on top of just playing edge then then
the norm doesn't you know it's not much
smaller than if we if it just play h ok
and so it means mean some other didn't
we we we play G in this additional
coordinate and some of the norms doesn't
isn't didn't change much ok what we want
to do now is we want to get some
something you know conclude something
about G just G so ok we would like to
say that this means that the value of G
is large and SNES an intermediate step
we will first show that the that you
know there's that there's someone non
negative function that satisfies this
property ok so let's let's see why this
is true so this ok let me know back so
now is the next step is quite important
but it's also you know completely
trivial and however you know the reason
why is complete review list because we
are in this analytical setup ok so it
would be somewhat intuitive in the
indoor original interactive proof set up
ok so what we do is that we view this
operator g g tensor h we view it as the
nodal product the matrix multiplication
of two other matrices and then namely g
tensor 8g times the density identity and
you know multiplied with the identity
tens of g tensor h sorry ok so this is
you know this these are the same
operators and with this and this is
operator we can you can factorize you
know in this in the same way we can
factorize this guy now this allows us to
2d couple of things ok so now we can
leave you with things you can view we
can think about you know first first
applying this operator and we get some
other function H and then applying you
know either g tensor the identity or
teach ends of the identity ok them just
doing things but some over like this you
know this this factorization it it
doesn't make much you know I don't know
of a good interpretation in terms of
interactive proofs but you know in terms
of operators it's very obvious yes like
H is some external system and you're
basically just taking conditional
expectation the quantum yes I mean yeah
I mean I think the other there several
ways of viewing muted but this I mean
okay what's going on here is very simple
I mean maybe also just to explain things
a bit more so you know if you look at
these matrices it's really just you know
blocks of H on the diagonal and blocks
off of G on the diagonal the thing is
that's somewhat maybe is non-trivial I
said you know it's different mmm like
you know one in one case that the you
know HSN on the right and the other side
geez you know geez on the left so it
would be particular it means that these
identities he are actually different you
know they act on different spaces so
these are different identities here now
we are in this situation no no you know
so here you know okay and now we can we
can sort of forget about this this this
right part and just focus on on what on
what happens if they have some function
H and turns out to be non-negative you
know because we got it by applying this
this is non-negative matrix so we this
function function will be non-negative
and now we apply this matrix to it and
this matrix to it so what it means is
that mmm GD chance at HSN sir I up how
does it act on H so it really means that
you apply G on the columns of H okay and
that's how that's how this so the column
any column here will be you know G
applied to the corresponding column here
similarly you know the columns here will
be
t applied to the columns here and we are
told that the you know that the norms of
this whole thing is been within a factor
of 1 minus Zeta of the norm of this
whole thing and so this means you know
that there has to be some column there
little bit such as the norm of this
column is within a 1-8 a factor of the
norm of this column okay and so that
means that you know this column will
correspond to some column of age and so
it means that you know this this column
of H if you apply G then you know it has
norm at least 1 minus ETA times T
applied to that column what I mean
column is nonzero I suppose ya se so yes
I should have said that I want some
nonzero f is but I mean like if I mean
if you know that this mean if HS I guess
which I just have to say that H is 10
here yes yes yeah but because I guess HH
was not already a zero this this house
this sort of this step so if you know if
the repeated game is large value then we
can find this is a negative function
it's now you know the way to interpret
this is that this is some kind of
Rayleigh quotient you know that norm of
T times F in the ratio to to the
compared to the norm of T times F is at
least 1 minus 80 now we want to go to
this we want to show that this means you
know the existence of such a non
negative function means that we can find
an assignment for g and here's where we
will use that Jesus next constraint
graph of G is an expander oh there's
everybody the sum into some
pre-processing or some his first to some
some simple step to simplify the
situation so the
whatever I have to wonder it but when I
wonder claim is it without loss of
generality we can assume here that f is
deterministic ok so what it means its
domestic it said it assigns nonzero
value only to get only two one of these
guys is it might not assign one they
might not assign one to to disguise by
did you know it has only won one nonzero
value to each of these clouds why is
that so so what we can do is you know
suppose if we look at one cloud and
suppose you know we see these kind of
values okay so we look at the cloud of
you and we see these kind of values you
know this is not you know this is not
atomistic okay three guys in 10 now we
can write it as a convex combination of
things such that you know each each each
of these guys are deterministic okay
only one nonzero and the nice property
is that like each of these guys they
have the you know if it's it it's the
sum of these values are invariant you
know so if you sum up hideous values
it's for and hear each of these guys
will have the same sum will be four but
what this means is that you know if you
apply t to this guy you know THX just
sums up everything in one cloud so you
by T to this guy or to any of those guys
it doesn't really make a difference of
you so so so T will not will not be able
to sing which between between this guy
or any of these guys ok and now so this
we have now we are now able to write FS
this convex combination of these guys
now you know G so you know so this
function if you think of it as a
function of F it's a convex function ok
so you know just because it's in a
linear function communal composed with
the norm so this is it this is convex
function and so that context you know so
that means that you know one of the one
of these ok
for one of these these guys in different
ending the convex combination the the
norm there has to be larger than for the
convex combination of these guys by
convexity we can you also pick one of
these one of these things in the convex
combination will have a larger norm and
on the other end you know the thing on
the right doesn't change it allows us to
assume that this function f is
deterministic so now you know just to
draw this picture F might have looked
like this and now after this argument
you know F looks like this okay so it
assign some nonzero value to each guy
now you know it's very easy to see
what's the kind of assignment that we
should use at this point you know we
should just you know pick assign these
these guys so the question is how good
is this assignment no no it's this this
is a situation you know the Rayleigh
quotient of G the norm of G times F is
roughly as large as the norm of F so he
we don't have to worry about G anymore
because you know T applied to this guy's
so if it doesn't really do anything now
ok I have to open up what what what this
what this means and you can think about
it in the inner in the following way so
you know be what it means is that we
pick we pick a random vertex we pick a
random vertex V on the left and then we
pick two random neighbors you and you
prime on the right and then we you know
we look at we look at the values of that
pc there for F and we vetted by by some
kind of probability by some you know
some kind of probability corresponding
to whether whether whether the
assignment that we have here are
consistent okay the reason is just that
you know in this picture here only you
know only only alphabet symbols that are
consistent with respect to our
constraints really contribute to the
discrete Attic form ok but so it's a
lesson that's you know don't worry about
this so mmm so let's just you know let
me tell you know just believe me that
this is equal to the norm of three times
f you know you know this is how can we
pass this so first of all you know
because we make this assumption that the
constraint graph of this game is next
pender you know this year this year
really corresponds to the critic fanatic
form of an expander and now if we you
know and this here some and this is this
there is some number between 0 and 1 ok
so let's you know let's let's replace
this by 144 moment and then you know
this inequality is still true and over
here you know BB we are told that we
have here some function f and it it you
know it's it's 1-8 are correlated with
an expander it'll be the quadratic form
of an expander ok because you know here
this is 1 minus 80 times the norm of F
but but expand us you know they they
don't have you know they only have only
the constant function can be can connect
or a only functions that actually very
close to the constant function can be
can be correlated with an expander
particular that mean that means that
this function f it has to be very close
to a constant function ok otherwise it
cannot be correlated with an expander
what this means now is that you know the
picture you know instead of having here
different values for for the function it
really looks more like this you know
that all the all the values are roughly
the same now now we can so using this
knowledge that F is you know close to a
constant function we can look at this
inequality and just replace F by the
constant function ok because f was close
to a constant function the inequality
will still be true and up to some fudge
factor but let's ignore the fudge factor
now if you replace in this inequality
you know f by the constant function what
you're told is really that you know this
i mean if this the average of these Q
values is large and if you should look
at what what it means that the average
of the cube alice is large it it's
exactly means that the assignment would
be extracted has s value close to one
that means that the value of the salmon
is closed now let me mention some
pensions so this was you notice the
proof sketch for expanding constraint
crafts now if you you know if the graph
is not an expander you you have to
modify the proof and but but a very
similar proof goes through so instead of
sort of using this rainy coercion test
except it's a way to understand the
value of a game you you have to use a
slightly more complicated as your entity
but it also has a nice interpretation so
one can interpret this is some kind of
operator norm for for the operator g
tensor the identity instead of instead
of instead of instead of using sort of
this argument that you know functions
call it with an expander therefore it
has to be close to a constant function
one has to use some kind of chico style
argument oh we remember one of the like
interests we are also interested in this
regime bear where the value of of the
game is already sub constant ok and
turns out that what you want to do in
this case is you want to use variance of
GE goes in equality that sort of apply
not not only if you have a function that
is very color coordinated with the graph
but but but in so this in this case
yourself in the situation that you have
a function that is only slightly
correlated with the craft and you
somehow want to you want to extract some
information from that in essence of a
variant of gos inequality applies in
this case or maybe let me not mention
what happens in the case of a few
repetition it tell you
open questions in this context so so we
saw that somehow this you know this kind
of some kind of operator theoretic
viewpoint and for analyzing parallel
petition and you know what we can ask if
if if this viewpoint is useful in other
situations for example you know can be
used to analyze other PCP constructions
or you can we can we may be combined
this viewpoint with this information
theoretic approach to to get better
thoughts thank you very much is there an
example of the statement that you don't
know yes so CV we focused on the case
that the constraints their projection
constraints and if general constraints
then you don't know how to prove it
using this over but for protection games
this you point to mentions to reproduce
all the balls
the constants I think the constants that
you get from here are better for
production games I mean and you know
it's the concern not not for epsilon but
you know not in the exponent of epsilon
but in front of epson actually one thing
I can also say that for certain classes
of for like large classes of games one
this one you're using this approach you
can exactly sort of you can estimate
exactly the amortized value of a game
meaning like the value that you get sort
of in the limit then the exponential
decay did you get in the limit so this
is kind of approach characterizes
exactly this value for for certain kinds
of games basically games that are
squares of projection games
next stop is it